it's really hard to support a  relationship that's really unhealthy  especially when it's hurting my brother  and now it's affected me and I just kind  of wish I could both stop this roller  coaster ride on Sunday's episode of  Keeping Up with the Kardashians Kylie  Jenner is upset that blac Chyna and Rob  were fighting in her house apparently  Chyna threw something at my television  that I left there it's just a little  disrespectful and I wouldn't do that to  anyone else's home on snapchat Kourtney  Kardashian shares a photo of newly  purchased nipple clamps and Katy Perry  becomes an honorary Kardashian go  pom-pom debuting her blonde braided  hairstyle with the caption Kati  Kardashian also an honorary family  member Kathy Griffin who looked  overwhelmed while babysitting Kim's kids  north and Saint  [Music]  you  [Music]